[Music]
shortly before 9 a.m.
fashion designer Gianni Versace was shot
on the steps of his villa this series is
based off a nonfiction book by Marie
North which entails a great deal of
investigative journalism we stand behind
marine and we stand behind the book we
all feel the utmost respect for the
Versace family for them the
assassination of Gianni Versace American
crime story premieres January 17th on SX
the cast stands by the miniseries but
the Versace family not so much
they told ET in a statement on Monday
quote this TV series should only be
considered as a work of fiction it was a
create it was a genius everything you
see around us this house this company
was his life have you heard from any of
the family about what they think about
the show what are your thoughts I can
speak on behalf of everyone involved in
the show we all feel the utmost respect
for the Versace family and we all tried
to be as respectful and as compact
compassionate as possible walking into
this show I did I read the statement
today and and listen Jesus Oh Jay
Simpson
you know the people versus objects
instant the the our show is based on a
non-fiction book written by an amazing
independent female investigator in
writer
Marie North so we stand by by her
reporting and I did and she said to me
if somebody is going to do this if
somebody's going to play me I am very
happy that is going to be you and we
spoke for an hour and that conversation
was very important to me and she's
really kind I hope she will be happy
when she sees that Marie North's book
vulgar favors was acclaimed and vetted
for almost 20 years now we send love to
Donatella and her family and I think
when you see the show I think they're
treated with the utmost respect and
kindness
Penelope never would have
taking on this role if in any way
Donatella or anybody in the family was
sort of portrayed in a negative light
you